having first of all been to Bletchley
Park I hope most of you have seen that
episode which is out there already we
also recorded some stuff about how the
listening services the Y stations got on
to this new type of traffic which
eventually needed Colossus to help the
decoding off this was this what later
became called the Lorentz cypher traffic
we covered that it was an exclusive all
kind of cypher and that lots of it was
picked up at listening stations and sent
back to Bletchley Park they knew that
this kind of cipher was very vulnerable
to attack if any of the German operators
ever disobeyed orders and sent out more
than one message using exactly the same
key settings on this Lorenz cipher
machine and preferably it would be good
if the naughty German operator sent out
two long messages were the same key
because then a very special technique
could be used to try and disentangle
what these messages were without even
needing to know the key at all now
that's an amazing property of exclusive
all you could perhaps even say it was a
weakness or a flaw but in wanting to
explain to you exactly how this worked
I thought we'd better do it first of all
with a simple example if I take the
letter A and don't forget we're using
five whole teleprinter code as discussed
in our video on five l paper to let us
take the letter A and add to it the
letter Q a is 1 1 0 0 0 Q is 1 1 1 0 1
and remember the plus inside a circle
means do a bitwise exclusive all so what
we'll get is the following that one
exclusive order that one exclusive all
says if it's the same thing you're
combining then the answer is 0 if
they're different it's a 1 so what this
comes out to be then one with one
another 0
zero with a 1 that's 1 0 1 so in fact
what actually happened and at this stage
you have to look back in your handi
teleprinter code sheet which will be
putting out a link to this what on earth
is zero zero 101 and the answer is yes
that's right it's H that then if you
like that's one of your plain text
characters this could be a key character
supplied by the Lorenz machine it's been
randomly generated somehow it goes
without saying that people at Bletchley
Park doing this stuff didn't even need
to deliberately commit this stuff to
memory they just knew it after hours and
hours and hours they just knew that T
combined with Z gave Yui what's
happening then here if you take
successive plaintext letters successive
randomly generated you hope key letters
is that you're ending up with a sequence
of plaintext letters I'll call this the
plain text stream this of course is the
key stream in the case of the lorentz
cipher machine it's pseudo randomly
generated it was not mathematically
totally random of course there would be
a repeat cycle but good enough to be
called pseudo-random out here of course
you end up with a shaft extreme one
thing that perhaps I should remind you
of if you're not aware of it already is
the sort of self reciprocal nature of an
exclusive or system and exclusive or
cipher we've generated a cipher text
character called e by adding together
under exclusive all conditions a
character T with a character Zed you
might say well what would happen if I
were to add the key character Z to that
once again okay so you've got the
subjects character but deliberately
again you rekey it with the same
character Zed you will end up back with
0 0 0 0 1 which of course is T so in
other words this thing almost cycles
round you can add T exclusive all is Zed
give you an E
he exclusive order where Zed would give
you bhakti and so on what we can now say
is let's try and find the weakness in
this cipher because it's been known
about ever since Victorian times since
the late 19th century you start off
saying the following I'm just going to
call the plaintext stream of characters
P it's not the character B it's not in
single quotes it's just the plain text
string ABC T whatever that gets
exclusive Ord with the key stream which
I'm going to call K and we get C fine
the cipher text string now special cases
within those streams that you have to
bear in mind when you come to look at
the detail for any particular plant
extreme key stream shaft extreme one or
two very special cases are so important
and here's one of them if you take any
plain text character I'll take a it
could be anything and your exclusive or
it with itself anything exclusive order
itself if it matches gives zero a with a
or B with B or said with said will
always give you five beautiful zeros
that nowadays is called a null character
many of you will know even ASCII has got
a null character what happens to your
terminal if you send it to null
character well mine just ignores it I
think that's the way most journals are
set up these days but ya know characters
were there in teleprinter streams as
well Bletchley Park certainly did not
want a null character that was generated
to be ignored and so they invented their
own notation which you have to remember
which says the null character is always
signaled by a forward slash what's the
other special case then the other
special case is if you ever get to a
situation of combining shall we say the
letter A with the slash character than
now if you think about it exclusive or
wearing any of those zeros with whatever
pattern a is it's like adding 0 in other
words it leaves the a totally unchanged
so a added on to the null character is a
K added on to the null character is K
and
thing added on to the null character
remains itself so I put a box around
these and let's just bear those in mind
for later on where's the problem come
then ok let's first of all take this
equation number file stuff this hope
we're not allergic to equations what I
can do look is this treated just like a
mathematical equation B plus K on the
left I'm now going to add on another K
to that and that doesn't matter it won't
change anything so long as I also add on
K to the right basically like you teach
you to say add X to both sides and or
whatever so fine but look what we've
just found any individual character
exclusive o'red with itself gives a know
anytime you combine a null with any
character
it gives any character back again in the
more general case therefore K plus K
adding together identical cipher key
letters will give you a stream of nulls
those stream of nulls when added to the
plaintext just gives you about the
plaintext it doesn't alter anything in
the plaintext so it's almost like
exclusive always like a - sometimes it's
like K minus K it's a zero it cancels
out yeah exclusive or is weird like that
it's like addition without Cary it's
like subtraction without borrowing its
symmetric so fine the k plus K cancels
out so in other words what we can say is
if you add the key back to the cipher
text you get the plaintext we did an
example of that so far what could be
wrong with this haha here's the problem
suppose Shawn sends me the first
plaintext message
p1 so instead of P is C plus K I'm going
to write p1 gives me ciphertext 1 plus K
and if there was a second plaintext then
that when added on to K gives the second
ciphertext so I'm just rearranging the
equation like that p1 p2 suffix 1 suffix
to okay
on that side now do yet another
exclusive or addition between left hand
sides and right hand sides and what you
get is p1 plus p2 exclusive or plus
equals c1 exclusive or with c2 exclusive
or with K exclusive water with K now as
we've just discovered that cancels out k
plus K you can ignore it so the net
result of all of this is as follows if
you send two separate messages using
exactly the same key the key cancels out
and what you end up with is something
where if you were to take the ciphertext
that you've received and intercepted
don't worry about the key as long as you
know it's the same key somehow or other
just exclusive or two pieces of
ciphertext together we'll do that let's
call it D so C 1 exclusive or C 2 is d
and that must be exactly the same as the
two plain texts exclusive Ord with each
other so essentially then it's like a
mashup
it's like an exclusive or mash-up of two
cipher texts gives you exactly the same
mashed-up characters as you would have
got by mashing up the two plaintext
together with exclusive or therefore it
follows if p1 plus p2 is the same as
this D I've invented then by shuffling
around and adding P 2 to both sides what
I'm saying is if I can guess a piece of
plain text called p2 and I push it
through exclusive or with this D thing
which I'll do for in a minute I'll get a
piece of p1 back so if I get some
plausible plain text from message number
2 and if it gives me plausible plain
text for message number 1 then I'm
winning because well then it might be
slightly different a piece of good sense
in one of them might give you something
you recognize in
the other well there's nothing like a
real-life example to make this come
alive and make you believe it really
does work sure sent me a 21 character
email message with a challenge to break
this top-secret cipher but I knew he'd
done it like this and I experienced just
like in the water I'm incident sort of
phone him up and sent Shawn my reception
apparatus and my program wasn't working
properly that ciphertext user sent me
didn't seem to work at all something's
gone wrong can you send it to me again
and once again you hope like in the war
that Shawn does not send exactly the
same message again but since it's
slightly different one because that
makes things much much simpler as well
see later so if we concentrate now on
this top block of stuff here here's
ciphertext one just as in good old
wartime Morse code tradition I'm
breaking this string of characters up
into blocks of five that was traditional
because of course he makes it so much
easier to read things if it's broken up
in this way
so these are spaces that you see between
every five they're not really there they
just to help you read if you ever do get
a genuine word space character and that
does exist in the five whole code then
Bletchley Park had their teletypes all
wired up to display a nine and that nine
men a word space here's the first
ciphertext W plus X a a blah blah blah
21 characters of it and then I say to
Sean oh whoa I didn't get it send it to
game wmj OG d wo and so on what I can
tell from that straightaway is that
since both cypher text starting with a w
and since they use the same key then I
don't at the moment know what the
plaintext letter was that started them
but I know it was the same in both cases
now as shown of course look W exclusive
order W thing with itself gives the /a
null character so what I've done here
between c1 and c2 is what I've just been
through on the theory exclusive all of
them and get this magical thing called D
mashup that's what I always call it of
the two ciphertex now successively on
either side of the mashed up ciphertexts
write down what you think is a plausible
piece of plain text and push that back
with exclusive all through the D string
and see if anything sensible comes out
for the other plain text now when to
start here on the second block down on P
to plain text - I'm assuming that Sean
was really fed up with plain text - and
he had to retransmit it and all of his
politeness will have left him he will
have started the second email message
with either a grunt or maybe just a
brief hi that's my guess anyway so I'm
guessing that in plain text - he might
have said hi space Dave or something
like that so here you see the nine for
the word space hi9 da V push all of that
line upwards through the corresponding
character combining them with exclusive
or what comes out and the answer is
hello oh I like that
now see this is where the cryptographers
you know heartbreak and joy if you get
it right it's wonderful but if you make
the wrong guess you've got to back off
and try something different very
frustrating strangely in this example I
seem to be making all the right guesses
so high nine Daffy comes back and be
hello nine in other words hello fall no
space ah so in the first one he probably
called me Dave as well maybe not sure
but we can at least take the DAV here
and promote it to the top line and next
time around we say if p1 is hello 9
Daffy push that through the exclusive-or
and the answer is then pizza will be hi9
hi Dave 9 another space this is looking
good sir we was being all informal is
then hi Dave in text oh honey looks like
the start of another world here yes but
we don't know anything about that yet
right now you have well in 1940 several
cigarettes many more cups of coffee now
where do we go from here
could it be the case that Sean is
using formal language in plain text one
hello David how about so we do that Hey
look at this the bottom then comes out
to be hi Dave
see SWE could it be see you soon see you
later
who knows but what we can do is if we
believe that C is right and is a great
word we promote that up to the top line
and make it be hello David
see but through an exclusive all comes
down on the lower line on the second
plain text Ben hi Dave see you weigh
bingo you he did he said hi Dave see you
now there's a well-known English phrase
see you later so we try of course late
down here propagate that back up to
exclusive-or and you get the word you
separated with spaces this is a fabulous
method of course it will only work for
as long as the shorter message doesn't
run out I can only guess that at the top
message which is a bit longer it starts
with our so almost certainly about one
would have said later as well but we've
triumphed and where the real triumph
comes is for these 21 characters you can
now go back to one of the equations I
wrote down for you and say we've got
cipher text - we've worked out plain
text to plain text 2 plus cipher text 2
will give you the key and here it is was
it generated by machine no I made it up
but there it is
and that's the moment of what you said
oh that's fantastic we can start to work
out now exactly what that wretched
machine might be doing that's generating
the pseudo-random key you start trying
to run two tapes simultaneously through
a piece of bespoke electronics which
they invented which will do the merging
but you must keep them in exact sync you
do not want differential stretching
between the two things